[Music]
you are getting married very soon your
beautiful fiancee backstage and she's
gorgeous Lydia Lydia and Lydia had a
what sounds like an insane bachelorette
party yes so Lydia went took about 20 of
her friends they went up to Hearst
Castle that's her family's she's related
to their to her her great-grandfather
was was William Randolph Hearst and so
they went to they went to this you know
palace in the hills and in kind of
central California and so and let me
quickly point out that that is a it's
it's been given over to the to the state
yes it's a park so most it's it's like
like any of us can go up there and party
at Hearst Castle but you can probably
get special dispensation yeah I mean
it's essentially like a museum so you
have to be very respectful of it you
have to be very careful you know you
can't you can't just go up a new look
yeah you can't just go throw a
bachelorette party she wanted to be very
careful of because so she said to her
friends like look we're all adults
please don't get any shape to anything
no straws no hats no goggles no suit
nothing note stuff and her friends her
friends were like to please and she was
like okay fine I will take care of it
I'll just get some penis cookies just 20
penis cookies so she ordered she ordered
she did she did what you do she went to
the internet to find her penis cookies
and and she ordered 20 they were kind of
expensive say penis cookie it could mean
it's shaped like a penis or it has
properties that help your opinion on
yeah you don't know you don't know have
a problem and you're like you can eat
your penis cookies no
I'm sorry I've been eating too much poop
yogurt and so she shorter 20 there's not
they were very expensive but ordered him
anyway about a week later what showed up
at our house she realized the cookies
are actually sold by the Dozen so she
ordered 20 dozen so we had almost 300
cookies in our house and we that's a lot
that's a lot of how'd you get rid of
them so I
[Applause]
my favorite thing about these okay you
gotta hold it still so a favorite thing
about these is my favorite thing about
these is you know I kind of thought they
were gonna be this kind of artistic
confectioner's and they're they really
they just look like you would have drawn
in your 10th grade chemistry but it's
just just like that but yeah my own time
[Applause]
a little music first a good lord why
you're not eating yours a lot of these
along here not again free I had too many
for lunch all right now listen I don't
like that tie to top you'll get to do
one here today you need to take these
cookies and going
[Applause]
hi Dave cookies were made out of real
yeah
sacrifice okay we think we have a
picture of don't we have a picture from
the bachelorette party above our look at
that yeah please
yes looming in the in the in the pool
inside and I don't know if I should say
this or not but they're all holding
cookies yeah yeah yeah thank you thank
you
well you welcome back to the Hearst
Castle no times I own yeah I know just
things gonna be all over the property
now well now what's gonna happen is
people gonna see this on the show and
wherever I go they're gonna be like
here's some more cookies for you Chris
Hardwick yeah now it's your thing yeah I
have those last name for it it's your
thing you just ate the shaft and left me
the ball
[Applause]
that's the first thing Emily Post
teaches all right who left all the balls
you